THE HARD SHOT, AND HE SCORES.
VASILEVSKIY.
THAT ONE JUST KIND OF ENDED UP
LOOKING INTO THE MIDDLE.
CAN I MAKE THE PASS?
NO I CAN'T.
IT WAS A REALLY GOOD SHOT
SHORESIDE.
HERE IS THE FLYERS CH
THE SHOT.
>> Brian:AND
SCORES. KED RIGHT NOW.
THIT BY A WHISKER.
>> Dave: THE POWERPLAY IS OV
THAT IS CLEARED BY THE FLYERS.F
THE NET.
YOU HAD CIRELLI IN THE MIDDLE.
YOU HAVE
HELD A SOLID EDGE OVERLL COMING
HANGS ON, AND NOW IT IS ON THE
NEAR SIDE.
TIME.  TO CENTER IT BACAC
HE SCORES.
COREY PERRY.WILL GO DOWN
BEHIND THE NET AND THEN DOWN
INTO THE CORNER.
HE
TURNED OVER HEDMAN.,
FINDS A E.
A BEAUTIFUL PASS
HE DOES THE ONLY THING HE
REALLY CAN ACCEPTTHE TEAM.
>> Dave: ALEX BARRE-BOULET.
FINDING THE TOP OF THE
HERE COMES
CUTTING BACK INTO THE MIDDLE OF
THURSDAY.
WHAT A WEEK HE HAS GOING SO